[Applaudissements]
ce soir les enfants bon sens
dépêche-toi nounours tu es ne veut
attendre je crois qu'ils sont impatients
de retourner chez leur maman je descends
les chercher patron à ma soeur emilia ce
qu'elle va être contente
bon les cher
papa
fall a
tué près je trouve qu'ils ont bien vite
passer vos vacances la prochaine fois
vous restera plus longtemps
bonsoir les enfants alors et nos petits
voyageurs au
score
ou qui le délégant
le joli nous six mois
elle va être contente ça mon cher
rubina
tient un ours tu lui donneras ses fleurs
de notre part attaché à sa merci des
enfants
les oursons prenez le flanc
[Musique]
voilà et pour toi pape rebelles
mongin à quatre fleurs comme le blues
mais aussi la 4e fleur d'une charmante
en couleurs dans la grille est invité on
ne peut le rose le corps raide riez
d'arrivée mais être très bon dans ses
boxes avec elle les fait tomber
le 6e congrès de finir leur 4è
cornichons n'ont d'autres champignons
non cotre boutures ont
même mois et les haies messieurs le
bouton de rose dans ce tout les 4 entre
eux allez quoi ton merveilleux quand le
sommeil élevé le ton dos rouge celle là
talent du nez dans la rosée
pour le reste la journée et vous
d'accord
we
all on le veut en route pour voir les
homos enfin les douches en a bientôt la
n va enfin mon petit casque a fait un
beau voyage
[Musique]
elle est toute fille de la maison ce
soir on leur creux de revenir connu et
comprenait pas nui qui feraient leurs
biens
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
allons ne soyez pas impatients
le vent est bon nous allons très vite
arrivée chez maman emilia août
bold huileuse rofo bonne nuit fais de
beaux rêves
[Musique]
oh
e
[Musique]
oh